machine learning for transcriptomic data
from raw reads to data exploration
machine learning and visualization this
is a preview of a workshop that we did
at the University of Nebraska in Omaha
on May 15
Kevon for platform was designed
specifically for research use but we're
using it for education we're building a
whole curriculum around the platform as
you can see this is the areas of
analysis that shows different types of
data that could be processed integrated
and analyzed on the platform today we'll
be covering this section called
transcriptomics there on top you can see
rna-seq and we also see us on your
screen and this section allows
processing and basic analysis things
like differential gene expression now
the second section over there on the
bottom is data mining and there we have
unsupervised and supervised machine
learning in methods so those methods
include things like principal component
analysis clustering and for supervised
classification things like SVM the third
part is annotation so once you have
those genes how do you imitate them in
terms of differential expression on
pathways as well as how you to skip from
ensembl ids to gene names and and
functional annotation so we'll look at
how to generate these pathway Maps and
how to look at annotation on the output
data type of data that we will be using
today is around modeling of precision
medicine so basically we'll use a cell
line data set and that was used to
investigate breast cancer and response
to treatment so why are we looking at
this data set so we have multiple types
of clinical subtypes of cancer for
example this is a mammogram you can see
here this white white area and that
supposedly is a tumor and now the
question is how to reclassify so one of
the
challenges is to identify the source of
the tumor so which tissue is it coming
from and one of the ways to you a one
other way to look at this is what
proteins are expressed in that tissue so
we can do immunohistochemistry but the
limitation is that as you can see here
we only have a small number of genes
that we can actually give that small
number of proteins so then we moved on
and now we have array data and array
data helps us to look at gene expression
and classify different subtypes of
cancer in this case breast cancer by
gene expression so you can see that red
is going to be a high expression with
green is a low expression and then we
can see that different subtypes are
expressed expressing different genes
differently why is this important
so first of all it's important to
predict survival you can see that here a
survival plot or a recurrence plot that
shows how this panel that we just saw
for microarrays separates different
subtypes of cancer in terms of their
survival over a number of years and you
can see a comparison of two panels here
on coke type TX and 1050 1050 is that is
something that we're going to be
discussing today the same approach is
used to select treatments so by looking
at the expression we not only know the
prognosis but we also can select more
aggressive less aggressive treatment or
combinations of treatment and finally we
can also start looking at targeted
cancer therapy right so how to not
select a generally toxic treatment that
kills some cell division but also select
something that interacts with a specific
pathway so obviously we need to select
which pathway that is so this is a broad
overview of a publication this is the
publication you have the link and you
can download all of this datasets
publicly available data set it combines
multiple types of omics data and
responds to treatment so it actually
measures half
time of complete elimination of division
of these specific kings ourselves now
all of these files are already prepared
for you so let's make sure that you have
all of the files that we'll be working
with
there was a download file button on the
page so let's find this file called
simples svl it's going to be under input
files under an expression quantification
if you open that file in WordPad they
look something like this okay so this is
what the file looks like inside what
does this mean this is just a reference
so instead of uploading multiple fast q
files which are large we're going to
take a number of references of files
that are already pre uploaded on the
server okay the second thing that you
will notice here is that each file has a
underscore one underscore two 9fq so
these are pair and files most of the
things that we are going to be
discussing today also are available
online these are courses called
transcriptomics one two and three they
cover all the basics of working with RNA
seek data so the first part of our
presentation is going to be around
sequencing and why it's important to
select it for an approach is to prepare
the data for machine learning so as you
know there's a genome and then we have a
gene a and gene B and those genes are
gonna be some are going to be expressed
and we're not gonna be expressed right
so when we have the sequencing data that
we're looking at weeds and those reads
represent multiple genes that are being
expressed now in reality this is a
little bit more complicated so there is
going to be shattering of those reads
and then there's going to be adapters to
those reads and there's going to be PCR
amplification and then finally we will
have the reading procedure so whenever
we look at raw reads
there's a little bit of a complication
and therefore whenever we do the RNA
seek analysis it actually consists of
three different steps
step one is pre-processing of the data
and notice the colors the colors are
going to correspond to what you will see
on the platform just so that visually
you will be able to spot those different
methods so pre-processing adapters
removal and additional trimming and then
removing the PCR duplicates mapping
which is mapping on a set of known
transcripts so genes that are known and
identification of novel transcripts like
isoforms and then we will also discuss
the combined strategy and finally
quantification how do we quantify the
alignment of these so this is the basic
pipeline okay so if we go to the
platform if everybody has the platform
you can go RNA seek if we click through
just to quickly explain to you how to do
this if you can do this together with me
you'll see that this is a very simple
and quick thing to do so first of all
you will see a selection here on top we
will be using our model genome here
organism we will select almost sapiens
grch38 fast queue files over here
and then over here we'll we'll use
parents ope as to remember we have the
svl file so instead of uploading
individual files we will actually go to
URL bulk upload ok and here we will use
the SPL file that you already have
darkus vo samples dot s VL it's a small
file so it should upload really fast
alright so now that we have the file
uploaded if you click on continue or
prepare groups you will see that the
list of files is on your screen correct
you see this and since we're not doing
differential gene expression we don't
need any groups so we can do cancel no
groups now we're ready to build our
pipeline so you can see that the buttons
that we can select are darkened out so
if you click on start which is no only
button but you should seek darkened now
you have a limited selection
remember the colors so what are the
colors we see blue over here
pre-processing is blue you can see the
red ones those are the mapping sections
okay and then you will see this one will
actually be green our same expression
table expression levels so let's start
with trimmer Matic dramatic is going to
trim those adapters so we're going to
choose that then we're going to do PCR
clean this will use an algorithm for
selecting duplicates that are not
related to the biological representation
of additional reads and now you can see
that the blue set action is complete we
have the pre-processing steps right here
then we're actually not going to touch
anything over here we're going to jump
over to bowtie to T which is mapping
unknown transcript so we're not
interested in new eyes or forms and gene
fusion and any kind of variation in that
you know we're just gonna map onto an
own GTF and finally you can see that
this is red and then finally our SEM
expression table let's click on that and
what you'll see here is a number of
selections that we will use to quantify
the number of reads right so what are
these values we'll talk about this in a
second in the meantime let's just do
fpkm and let's click on one or I can
give your pipeline a name you can save
it now you can run it on your account
I'm not going to run it because it will
take some time and I already have the
prepared output file so I'm not going to
be running this right but what you will
notice is under my pipeline's you can
see the pipeline that I've created
now if we return to the presentation so
this is the pipeline that we built we
built this pipeline and our goal is to
get an expression table you look over
here this
directions for you to create a new
pipeline we're not going to spend too
much time on this because we don't have
that much time but let's do it for
practice if you can follow along you
completed the previous steps everything
went well let's try and do this all
right so this is what your pipeline
should look like by now and here you can
see expression quantification a folder
called expression quantification now
this is important to understand because
before we can analyze any kind of table
using advanced machine learning
techniques we actually want to
understand what are we looking at what
are the features so what are the rows or
columns that we have and what are the
numbers in those cells so let's take a
look at these two tables so what you'll
see is you actually have two different
table tables one called expression genes
fpkm and or not filter and one called
expression genes fpkm so if we go back
over here this is what this looks like
and you can also open the file in Excel
so let's open this file in Excel I'm
using a Mac here so you might be seeing
something a little bit different but
basically any table manipulation
software is going to work unless it's
made by Microsoft now let's take a look
really quickly what are these IDs over
here on the side right so these are gene
names these are ensembl gene names and
we can scroll through and we will see
that there's a whole lot of them so go
all the way to the bottom there's
something like 20,000 genes here what
are the columns so let's go to the very
top and in the columns you can see that
the name of the sample is going to be
the name of the column so basically
we're looking at expression of an
individual gene across multiple samples
okay
let's go back to our presentation and
take a look over here
gene ID so if I have a gene like p53 for
example expressed over different samples
I'm interested in the variation how
those numbers change across multiple
samples that will give me some insight
into how these samples are different by
their expression values now can you
select the second gene in your table and
the second column so the third column
from the beginning or the second sample
and tell tell me what is this number
what is the number that you see in that
cell
I'm using entered one filtered
okay so to understand what this number
is
I hope you found it right so you
remember what that number looks like but
let's take a look at what it means so we
have a number of ways to quantify the
number of reads that were aligned to
that segment and here we're looking at
the fpkm
value so fpkm and TPM are two methods of
normalizing those values against the raw
counts that is also one of the options
that was available in the settings that
we had the raw counts are just looking
at the number of those fragments
repeated but fpm and TPM actually
normalize it for the length of the gene
so if you think of a very long gene and
a very short gene the number of repeats
of those genes is going to mean
different things so we have to normalize
it against some universal value and
that's a million reads right so you can
see fragments per kilobytes per million
map reads so those are the two ways of
normalization well now I'm going to go
too much into detail here just for the
sake of time but just to explain what it
means the second way to normalize these
values is to use logarithmic scale so if
you remember the logarithmic scale
basically reduces the numbers in such a
way that very low and very high numbers
are going to become closer together so
instead of looking at huge variation we
are looking at variation that is
normalized now let's review this really
quickly before we proceed to the next
stage the first part that we did was
pre-processing so we use traumatic and
PCR clean traumatic reduce the adapters
PCR clean reduce the amplification that
PCR base the second step that we did was
knocking we used a mapping algorithm
that pathari on a specific Chinese we
quantified those numbers so instead of
just looking at the reads we use
complicated formula and generated values
in F PKA now does this even matter a lot
of people
the question whether this matters the
pre-processing the trimmer mattock and
PC are clean we could select raw table
without any pre-processing and we could
do a table with the pre-processing which
is what we did right you remember in the
names of our samples it actually says
that it's pre processed right so here we
did a comparison and basically in this
comparison where you can see is in the
upper corner where the values of
expression are high you will see that
the values are going to be skewed if we
don't do the pre-processing steps ok
that's just to say that whenever we deal
with gene expression those
pre-processing steps are going to affect
primarily those genes that are going to
be highly expressed and why is that
important because highly expressed genes
typically alright so quick overview of
RNA seek I hope it wasn't too basic but
if it was this was just to bring
everybody up to speed and so that we all
understand what data were working with
we do have a few previous workshop
questions that came up so if you just
look at the pipeline you'll see that
there are other sections and other
buttons that we didn't cover error
correction different types of mappers
and other sections doing differential
gene expression and segmentation what
are those in two words error correction
is primarily used for microarray data or
older sequencers whenever the older
sequencers were used that quality of the
quantification wasn't very good you had
a lot of base pairs that were replaced
and so these error correction methods
and reduce those the bias that came as a
result of that different mappers what's
the significance of different mappers
different mappers use different
algorithms and they could be useful in
specific situations so some papers that
you will read use stars some paper use
top hat but basically it's your
preference there's some more updated and
less updated ones
the choice that you have to make
differential expression we have a number
of different options for differential a
differential expression all of them
function in a very similar way but again
there is some more updated once and then
segmentation so segmentation is a
separate section that requires its own
explanation
just to let you know that it's available
there and once you do segmentation
you're looking for completely new
segments instead of being expressed
sometimes it's useful to annotate those
using blast X so you will see that
section there as well
alright now part two I'm gonna give it
over to teach Devon here he's gonna walk
you through how to use this table and
use machine learning to identify
patterns in this table so first let's
start from definition of machine
learning actually machine learning is
separated into two huge categories one
is unsupervised machine learning and
secondly supervised machine learning
let's begin from unsupervised machine
learning and suppose that we have a set
of images and actually we don't know is
this dog or is this cat so we have
unmarked images and the task of
unsupervised machine learning is to
split these images not mark the images
into several categories for example here
we can split into two categories cats
and dogs so machine learning we have
unsupervised machine learning we have
unmarked samples and we want to mark
them if if it's possible okay we can
show these samples on the cloud on the
scatter plot and absolutely we can have
outliers here and our algorithm can make
errors this is not prohibited every Lu
and make error so let's return to our
data our data we have some samples and
some genes so
our cone currents our samples and our
rows are gene names and we want to apply
a supervised analysis methods to our
samples so we want to see if there any
division of our samples including some
groups which is which can be for example
biologically meaningful for example
different cancer types or samples and
let's take a look for first methods
principal component analysis this is
just a method for visualize for
visualizing the data for example imagine
that we have only two genes so each
sample is associated with words
expression of the first gene and
expression of the second G in this
situation we can make the scatterplot
yep we have two numbers at each sample
and we can draw it and see that this is
the first group and this this second but
actually we have a sent several thousand
dreams or more and we can't draw it in
two in our claim so it is points in
seven thousand dimensional space so
principle component analysis is just a
method for optimal projection of high
dimensional data to the plate
so for example imagine we have a pan
three dimensional object and I project
it to some clay so if I will protect in
this way I will see only one point here
yeah and I can understand that this is
this is a pan by this projection and if
I will project in this way I will see
actually ad and so not not each
projection is group so principle
component analysis is an optimal
protection which maximizes information
which we can obtain from this projection
so how to use it let's go to our
platform okay and let's click upload
files here we here our files are not
huge so we can just like
quails and go to the info file section
here we have unsupervised 7,000 jeans or
folder and let's select cell line six
expression data dot txt not marked one
choose continue then start then we
select PC eighth row not to see to say
row to have a plot here we use default
options save and go to the end or signs
of name to the our pipeline PC a they're
simple PC safe and then we can run this
pipeline so if I click run pipeline I
need to run it and then I can go to the
my pipe art section and see that state
of this pipeline is started so it's
running now and as we said we prepared
output files output files folder and
select here unsupervised PC a 7,000 in
slow marked and here we see our crews of
our pipeline so it contains one PDF we
can open it and see our samples on the
plane so it's just the optimal
projection of our seven thousand
dimensional data to the plate and here
we see two groups yep this first group
and this second group has some natural
division and actually we work with
cancer cell lines data so we have new 52
samples and actually these fifty two
samples are already grouped
to the four categories for different
types of cancer and we can draw same
plot by assigning colors to these groups
you will see four groups this one type
of cancer second third and one more so
actually we've seen only in Division two
two groups but actually there are four
loops and here is some important idea
that we have seven thousand tweets it's
a huge number and we have a lot of
information but we have a lot of noise
with these soundings and the idea is
that if I will reduce number of genes so
select some some Peter's my plot can be
my data can be plotted better so for
example if I I won't take 58 genes from
m50 panel my blood became better here
you see you will see some three groups
actually we don't see four groups
because 150 panel is not aimed to our
four groups but there are two groups
which are invited
okay groups and let's go on to the next
unsupervised analysis method called your
Coldplay story so first method is just a
method of visual so visualizing data and
this hierarchical clustering is not a
method of clustering bonito so let us
create a pipeline go to them and
supervise the analysis section upload
we upload same file press Continue start
here we have h class button and we need
to change some options here for example
we see link age is default to single we
need to change it to word dot d - I will
explain what it means and we expect for
example four clusters here and then our
save and go to the end assign some name
to the pipeline h crust c and then we
can run this paper it is running now so
not to waste much time you can see
already results in your output files
folder
hierarchical clustering seven thousand
genes and here we see two PDFs okay let
me explain the idea of hierarchical
clustering first and then look to these
PDFs imagine we have points on the plate
now this these are points in high
dimensional space but imagine that is
white points on the plane and at at the
first iteration we assume that each
point is a cluster so we have one
element clusters view at the second t at
the second stage i've found two nearest
clusters so our clusters is one element
we found two nearest points and then we
merge these two clusters so now I have 1
2 element cluster and our other ones are
one element clusters and then I repeat
this procedure then I found new two
years plus
for example to end and so on for example
on this on this stage we merge these two
and at the end of the procedure we have
one huge cluster all points and this
procedure can be visualized by plotting
a pentagram what is it
it's a 3/8 of the 3 is a distance
between points so rate of dissimilarity
for example if hate is low so at the
bottom that means that samples are
really close to each other and if it is
high it means that they are far enough
and on this plot we see you will see
four clusters for example this is first
cluster because these points are similar
and they are not similar to other other
ones here's a big second cluster is a
third cluster and this cluster and we
can cut this tree to mark our samples
for example we can cut our tree at this
place so this line intersects our tree
at two positions so this gonna be first
cluster and this we can cut this place
first second third okay and now a little
practice you see that we have sample
names that are leaves but also we have
filed in input files directory let's go
input file
so in Greene's expression data marked
let us open it in Excel okay or on here
and we see that music is already
modified now before that we had both
logs we have sample IDs and the group
names but now we're just having one line
and so you just use the file as it is
and run the H+ string pipe line that
looks something like this there's a key
so we see that our division is actually
correct
here we see one group is a huge subtree
second small one and so we see that
basil group is actually very similar or
to normal like group they are shuffled
now about supervised machine learning we
have really different concept here here
we have training set just images with
labels so they are already marked by
somebody and then we have a test set
some pictures and samples which are
unknown and we want to train our
classifier on training set and then make
some prediction on test set so we want
to assign a label to each picture in the
test set so in our expression tables it
means that we have some samples with
known clinical cancer subtype and now
new sample arrives and
you want to assign a clinical subtype to
eat okay and here we have some methods
for doing that and let's start from
stepwise linear discriminant analysis
stepwise Lda we can run it by going to
the supervisor analysis section okay let
me show the input files first they are
in input files folder here we have
supervised 7,000 genes and here we have
two files first is called train and
second testing said we have labels so we
are sample names and here are group
names so they are marked and the
training set the training set contain
unmarked samples so we don't have group
names you and our task is to mark these
samples we just need to upload these two
files to the platform at files well
supervised 7000 tests so we have both of
them then click continue
we'll start stepwise LBA and we need to
modify this statistical threshold just
add some zero and change 5 to 9 this
experimental estimated threshold so
people parameter for the algorithm then
save
okay wanna run pipeline this pipeline
will take about five minutes
and how did I obtain these two training
and test files
I just taken randomly one part from huge
stainless training set and the other
part hardness test set so actually I
know real classes were for test set so
let's take a look at our food our files
supervised snack nights l v8 and we here
we have file called prediction test
let's open it and here we see that
classifier assigned route name to each
sample so as I said I know real classes
and classifier made one error on this
sample Oh actually it's normal like and
it said this is basil so this is normal
for classifiers so we can't achieve 100%
accuracy and why we selected stepwells
ld8 we have some bunch of methods
because stepwise lde reforms feature
selection you will see stepwise speed
record coefficients txt we can open it
and we will see some gene names what is
these genes these dreams are marked as
informative by the stepwise MVA so it
used them for classification procedure
so we just can take these genes they are
located at input files annotation 15
genes file and these are highly
informative
so then we can use these 15 genes for
another methods of classification for
example for support vector machine so we
will not speak today about this but idea
of feature selection is very important
because many supervised machine learning
algorithms can't work when when we have
really big dimensions
so when number VP supervised analysis
algorithm can be can can't be applied in
this situation so for applying them we
should select features first and
stepwells lv8
or random forest classifier are our
friends in this task so they confirm
feature selection ok and then Luke let's
look how feature selection can affect on
unsupervised nor analysis so now when we
have fifteen informated genes we can
rerun our pca with only these 15 genes
and here we see that the plots that plot
really looks better so we removed all
noise and we say that looks really
pretty and we here we see four rules
remember last Clause only two groups and
here we see all the routes and it's
hierarchical clustering also this looks
better now four clusters and now basil
and normal like our loss happened as in
the previous case okay that's about
supervised analysis
all right so the main question now that
we're going to be working with is we
have these 15 genes what are they how
can we understand what pathways they
belong to you what could they
functionally keep so you have this table
of 15 genes and we're going to create a
quick little pipeline under the
utilities section that will help us
annotate those gene in ensembl IDs to
actual gene names so transfer this table
to what you see on your far right ok and
here we go to areas of analysis
utilities upload the file that we can
add the file and here by the way you
have a couple of ways of doing this if
you're interested in keeping your gene
expression you can just take the input
file or location you can take this one
or you can also take this one with
expression values in our case let's just
take the simple table so that we see
everything close together click on start
annotation on here take a look at the
settings so you have what databases do
we have here represented so we have the
ensemble so EMS at the beginning of the
gene ID is ensembl and so we have this
database and also we want to do gene
ontology categories right so we can
select yes or no ok we just want to
specify that we do have a header that we
have sample names and number of columns
that it starts with so which column are
the EMS gene names in column number 1
right so let's save that and
one pipe one now as you can see in the
result once you've done your pipeline
you will get something that looks like
this a gene ID gene symbol gene
description gene ontology domain
category etc so what we can see here are
two good examples dcn and F camp now
these are files that were in the black
box selected by simple eyes okay and we
want to see if there's any relevance of
these genes to what we see in cancer
biology so first of all remember this is
the heat map that we built right and
here we can see those two genes
highlighted as well so the first gene
that has green in the first samples and
kind of you know goes to green again
another sample so it's not really
present in a lot of these samples and
the one towards the bottom some of it is
highly expressed across the syllables
but in our case let's take at a
comparison of these two groups so we
will compare cloud and low and normal
life so instead of looking at everything
we will just look at two small groups
okay so what are these two genes these
one of the genes is actually a known
uncle gene called decorum DCM stands for
the quorum
you can see here a couple of
publications on this and we excluded the
slide that actually shows the variation
well let's quickly take a look to make
sure that this radiation does make sense
so tell me if you have the annotated
file ready let's take a look okay you
see mine is done I'm gonna just go down
here 15 genes out
and I can see
the first gene one four one one four six
five is DC n hey so this one is the gene
of interest and now I'm doing
interpretation part of the work so I
want to take this gene let's just see
it's variation across all the samples so
what can we see
okay what can we see here we can see
here well let's explain a little bit
more okay you can see that all the cloud
and low are highly expressed right this
one this one this one but apparently not
all of them right so two of the cloud
and low are not highly expressed there's
some basil that are already also highly
expressed and then it seems like all the
rest luminal most of the basil or low
expressed right so if we go back to the
presentation and we take a look at these
publications here we can see what they
are related to so the presentations tell
us that one is extracellular matrix and
tumor microenvironment and other one
talks about prevention of metastatic
spreading and breast cancer what do you
think this might indicate for the cloud
and low with highly expressed gene
you think they are related to what does
this suggest so is metastatic good or
bad back right so we now we've
identified some quality of those tumors
might suggest that one is a little bit
more aggressive another one is less
aggressive which one is more aggressive
the one where it's high expressed or low
expressed highly expressed you're saying
highly expressed is bad is that we're
saying
so dcn decorum is an oncogene right in
terms of oncogene it's related to cancer
we're not going to call uncle team
typically means it drives cancer of
progress but in our case it's a gene
we're later to a cancer right so but
it's high expression is it good or is it
bad in the patient that high expression
is bad well let's look let's look over
here like the corn prevents metastatic
spreading and breast cancer so what do
you think is it good right so it's like
a tumor secure so it's not a tumor
suppressor but it prevents metastatic
again so it's over maybe high expression
if we detect high expression that makes
the cancer a little bit less dangerous
what could this imply for the treatment
of that breast
so in cancer one of the primary goals in
early detection and treatment of cancers
to stop metastases stop it from
spreading to other tissues and across
the body right because when it's
localized we have simple methods of
dealing with it what are those methods
so good so yeah we can cut it out or we
can do Radio 30 right so those are the
two basic ways of doing it and why is
chemotherapy more dangerous for example
well because chemotherapy is going to be
given to the whole body but it's gonna
go everywhere and potentially more
likely even cause other cancers right so
now we have an insight right it's not
anything proven but at least it puts us
on a track during some biomedical
application all right so here we have
what we're trying to paint the picture
is that we had some raw data nobody told
us how to generate this raw data it was
a machine my machine sister generated
twenty thirty thousand genes look at the
genes knew nothing about it and then we
ended up with 15 genes that actually
makes some sense in terms of applying
that information towards further
investigation of potentially in the long
run if it's confirmed using it for some
method of treatment now before we go on
and stop me and just tell me so you also
there's anybody online we have prepared
projects like this one yet the
satellites that go through the full data
set so here we're talking about a small
subset of the samples we take you're
only one type of data in the project
here it goes through the genomic data
and uses multi-omics integration to
actually work through what the paper
discovered in terms of assignment of
specific treatments but we also have
other types of projects here analysis of
the changing immune of response in
cancer and whole transcriptome profiling
of cancer tumors in mouse PDX models and
even at ECG
so full pan-cancer type analysis
homework whenever you have time I was
going to grade you on this but for you
to try it out you can try the PCA plot
with the 15 genes we showed you the
picture if you want to try and do this
at home you've got all the data if you
run PCA see what you do well you get and
also beans from the differential
expression analysis that's about your
question we make we from differential
expression analysis for normal life
group and cloudy low group of small
groups and here we have some 1215 high
informated genes for separating these
two groups and you can try to plot all
52 samples with these 15 genes and blue
and compare with previous 15 genes which
looks better so where do you find those
files under output files you have this
folder so under a hands-on top 15 genes
we said to our processed and you can
just use that file and if you don't know
how to deal with that file and what are
the values inside photo transcriptomics
2 3 4 so we'll explain what to do ok now
we're going to skip a section of our
presentation because of the limited
times and we're gonna go to the section
dedicated to art so one thing that we
wanted to make available on the platform
is continuity potentially two other
methods that are people that people are
using in the lab or other courses that
you thinking coding and visualization
and what we did and you can see in this
little video is after you complete a
pipeline you probably notice that
there's an occipital called our PAC so
for example ECA will have a full zip
file called PCA our hot
okay now let's go to the folder called
five platform arts tweets
here we prepared for sweets for dealing
with pah posturing SVM a stepwise Lda
today let let us consider pca yeah great
we can open it okay and here we see the
call each file starts with needed
libraries so you can install them in
order to run this and that so we have t
see a plot dot PDF on it already
and we see just one flick and sweet
works okay let's go through it we see
options from the platform remember we
were selecting something like transpose
center scale
how many principal components to grow in
the web interface and here we have all
these options in the code so you just
can modify input file we can transpose a
data or not centered data scale and so
on so this is just simple script not not
so simple as if you write it by your own
hands but okay so let's start just look
by code chunks first we read the data so
we have it has Heather we have row names
in first column
and that so then it's option to
transpose the data so we have done it we
have already done it for use and we
don't respond to danger a bar sometimes
not so simple because we have some text
columns next rows and this all are
already handled yep
then we assign some group names and
here's a mainline calling PC ages PRC
from function is from stats package
already insult in the are building
package and then about drawing you will
see PDF and if you are writing and by
the script or something else perhaps you
want more beautiful plot than this is
yep
so you can modify this screen and we
have already improved script in our code
directory we have to say phone holder -
it is a file for generating such
pictures so you see that we have where
percent of variation explained by the
principal components you will see some
group labels and we have sample names
instead of points and let's see how we
can modify our script to draw beautiful
beautiful pictures so you see that first
first rows are probably at the same we
just 12 the data that with the tables
transpose it here we expose assign new
owner new
plus two expressions if you want we can
go really through and just analyze teach
line we want it or just go to
visualizations section okay let's see
how we can visualize in previous in
platform code we use ggplot2 library and
me we used GG forty-five libraries just
and package for able to pca plots and
here we see how it works the function is
called out of word he will play he would
pass result of pca so here I applied PPC
and I passed this object to the justice
argument then I say from which column to
take colors to our roots here I have
some data frame called groups with
column with group names and I say that
please take the comes from that data
frame then I have option label is true
which just rows label names of this plot
and yes I can label size shape equal
false let me set it to true and see what
happens if I will zoom a little
happened yeah and now I removed shape
equal false and I see points you some
tape some tape it's just a argument for
growing points I think that they are not
needed now it's more beautiful without
them okay and then frame is just for
drawing these Alex's here and here we
have option frame type and just for
practice please remove it and look what
happens that's wrong school by yourself
if you have some problems so if you open
our studio first timing in this folder
you need to go P into file to bed
you
and you see that we have polygons
okay so and I have commented there are
some other options which are perhaps
hard to understand because there are
some mathematical meaning but let's let
us uncomment these streams and see what
will happen
so are you following me and running that
you
Oh
you
ok so these arrows are called loadings
and what it what does it mean let us
imagine for example three dimensional
space and three axis you know they are
orthogonal to each other and what
actually can see a to each select one
more set of axis for example just like
this and then may make a projection to
to torque them and then we can project
initial access to so these axes are
projections of initial axis and our
initial axis was gene names yeah
so for each arrow we have gene name and
how to interpret this picture for
example let's take this thing we can see
if we grow by direction of this arrow
then expression of these genes is
growing so and we see that these two
groups are located these two groups and
this group are located just on the line
of this arrow so if follows then big
values of this chain expression are
associated with these two groups and
small values with this group so we can
just go by these arrows and see how the
gene expression affects the separation
of the groups so it is really important
and we see that some genes are not
important you know that's
we've expression wearers of these pins
mainly correspond to the disco
because arrow girls here and small
values correspond to these two groups so
it's a yeah so better projection of
initial access which really makes sense
to use yeah and most long arrow is the
most amazing game in our case ok they
are yeah just direction it we have this
one so it's just a combination we feel
it's hard to imagine which means
projection from 15 dimensional space to
them playing with some huge combination
of extras okay and that's about at PCA
now we can we can try to remember we
created a heat map and we've seen that
to obtain much information we need to
replace columns just by colors and this
is really difficult to do manually and
we can use heat map in our and it
automatically does this column
replacement and we will see a really
beautiful heat map which indicates that
this is the first group second we have a
code for it in our code direction
there's a heat map folder and we can
open it let me close our studio and open
it on this director
okay
started just pretty same that in PCA we
just load the data and transpose because
all all machine learning methods
actually wants to sample the row names
not common needs but for biology is more
convenient to use it back on so we need
to expose them each time okay and here I
have a huge eat map goal and less reduce
it and step by step up and some options
and see what they actually mean
so let me okay
oh no can see it one moment I need to
run let install this memory okay now
let's see PDF now that is you see power
of our just comparing with Excel but
here we have some your article
clustering which which orders these
Romish groves and here you see just some
groups that they are all red with green
and just they are all sorted in proper
way so let us see how it works and which
options do we have
Scofield taste here and command this one
and remove all options from here so
calling these map from scratch and art
okay that's how it looks okay so I'm
just you can just remove all options
from this pole just leave expressions
okay and here how roll heat map Colleen
looks like let's look at the differences
should I open it one more time okay so
first we have some density plot on the
color key that means that red values are
used more frequently than these yellow
values yep so we have what a lot of red
cells are heat map but actually people
don't like this
and we want to remove it so for that we
can use density information no here we
run and see no dancing
well these strange lines near strange
traces what is that at each column we
have some dashed line which indicates
the
a mean expression level here is it just
orange color and if our value is lower
the mean level then solid line is drawn
at left of this dashed dashed line and
if it is yellow its it has drawn at the
right so I don't know why it should be
used and why it is the default option in
each map to function so every time you
want to draw heat map first of all you
to these two options here just to
prevent traces and density info and then
our heat map is more you are
so what we want that then we see that
our gene names are not fitting in our
PDF they are truncated here
so we can add some margins for example
12:12 you can modify these values as you
want and you'll see that now really fit
you okay and then we see that row name
sample names are covering each other and
we want to reduce font size or that we
have option C X row so zero point one
point five is a percent related to the
initial font scale so when I type zero
point five it means please add font size
two times two times less than initial
one when when we run it we see that they
are not overlapping here and this is
great and the most challenging part is
them to mark groups in this pot because
we know that H clustering it's just
hierarchical cluster here it reordered
our rows and we see some groups you for
example we see yellow they're red
they're wrong right there and we think
that these reordering actually matches
with our groups or four times and we
want to add some colors to indicate
which group is where for each there's a
there's an option called wrong side
colors in which you need to pass array
of
others associated with each of the group
needs so for that we should prepare this
array first so we have a array called
groups let us print it see what it what
it is here's goop goop is just an array
top line is a header will group names
and we want to convert them into the
colors for that we initialize an empty
array of repellers iterate through
groups and just some ifs if normal like
orange and so on and after that we
append a deist color to their o colors
array just by calling C doing on word C
means in our C's just for creating an RA
arrays so we just concatenate to erase
this line and then we can pass this
option to the heat map and see that
think that which is not possible to do
in Excel you see that
thisis luminal group and I don't
remember
[Music]
[Music]
don't tell her so we just put the
different
the question you only want any that
asked you here
Rosen's not only to open it go to the
phone where the file close it now
then I try to see you look so slim home
okay really took selfies was installed
packages here yeah
okay just white white right but what's
what's interesting yeah you every point
out is that this little section is
unique to this group right away jokes on
it anything else that you've seen in
this example
so much penises yeah okay so when we
found out from this little exercise is
that we have a heat map that is more
easy to work with we also can quickly
find genes that are of interest based on
their expression so yes and one more
thing there that remember we set linkage
type two words dot let's let us see now
let me run this and we see that there
are some some kind of not perfect
reordering
you see that this group is splitted by
orange group and there are two luminal
types so word dot d tu is just another
modification of all the algorithm which
affects to the way how distances between
clusters are calculated and if we append
this long long line here it will use
this linkage type for for dendrograms
and here you here you see better
clustering and here we see for example
an outlier here is it and it's actually
luminal but it's more similar to
non the purple wait I'm not gonna sculpt
soit since we have quite a lot of time
yes let me go through differential
expression okay well let me okay so the
thing that we would like to finish with
and this is a little bit different than
the logic I think of what we typically
would expect in a progression but up
until now to summarize what we have is
this okay let me go see if you can I
just want to do a little summary of what
we have done so far
okay so we saw that there is a basic
challenge in working with raw data it's
hard to interpret and it's hard to
navigate even the process that it
because it has so many different uses
now an RNA sink there's a few ways to
look at the differences between samples
we either can have a simple separation
of just two groups or we can have
multiple types of groups and classes and
then we need to apply more advanced
methods so in this session we looked at
transcriptomics processing or NAC
processing section we went through how
to do a typical expression table with
pre-processing and quantification and
then we looked at data mining to look at
unsupervised methods where we just look
at the groupings within the data or
patterns within the data and then use
that pattern to train and classify a new
sample for for example a group of
samples this section we haven't touched
on but it's very useful so you can see
here the pathway with different colors
right and so when we look at
differential gene expression this is a
very useful thing to do because we can
annotate pathways and we actually can
see the expression of genes on those
pathways so let's take a look back at
the RNA seek pipeline so we'll open back
this section okay and we'll quickly
create an differential expression
pipeline and in the meantime talk about
how it's useful so in our little
exercise here in our exercise we saw a
pretty clear difference between cloud
and low and normal life so if we can
take again those two groups
and create the same pipeline that you
see over here so what are we gonna do
we're gonna do pre-processing again so
PC a traumatic to remove the adapters
PCR clean to remove the duplicates then
we're gonna map it on transcripts so
we're not going to be looking for new
isoforms or anything like that we're
going to generate an expression cable
and then from there we're going to use D
sex you or our or edge R to do
differential gene expression okay so
let's look at the files we specify
groups
so let's first find the file stainless
feel okay yeah so in our input files
expression quantification we have the
samples as we L so as you remember on
top we specify there and and over here
we specify human genome 28 upload files
and groups sorry URL bulk upload input
files expression quantification samples
as VL well now we can define groups so
we'll have two groups so yes how many we
have one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten
so 11 samples total the bottom five are
are going to be in Group one or you beat
and the cell the rest and you pay if you
just drag them like this
what okay so you should see something
like this you have two groups six
samples and one five samples on the
other all right continue here we have
something for segmentation it's not
going to be used here but just do select
all submit all changes and then we can
continue so start trimmer Matic PCR
clean go Tai Chi Chi are some expression
table and then whichever one you want
I'll use ESET - oh okay then you would
click on
my plan again it's not necessary for us
right now let's just take a look at the
outfit boss okay so let's go to the Y's
it alone okay so this is a little bit
more clear right so we have false
discovery rate we can it's already
sorted for us so we see that above a
certain threshold like so we can select
for example am 50 right so Pam 50 is a
50 gene panel right so we can just take
some number and like once it 50 I'll
just select the top 50 or we can try and
work with the values right and here we
have FDR is basically the p-value
adjusted for the total number that we
have and we can set some threshold for
example you know if I just give the
first option so let's just take the
first 50 I will have 50 gene names again
an ensemble ID that I will want to use
for annotation so then I want to see
what types of differentially expressed
genes so not only differentially
expressed individual genes but what
pathways are in so quickly if I take
this table that I got over here and I go
to areas of analysis utilities and I use
this edge or table okay so here I have
in this edge our table
and over here I have this button called
human gauge so the human gauge again
gives us a lot of options here but
basically let's look at a few things
over here so what types of outputs are
we going to be interested in right until
we saw the table so we saw this FDR
column over there right so we we can use
this threshold to make it either less
jeans or more teens over here we can
look also what type of tag database we
will use right so we have you know a few
options over here okay and then we can
look either at downregulated upregulated
or combined options and we'll see the
output here in a second okay so we see
column name headers present where the
gene IDs are and then where are the
actual expression values right so that's
okay so here we have a jar so again over
here let's see if you want to go back in
the platform you just do a right click
okay so I can select it again so where
is my differential expression measure
right so here it's on column two let's
see where is it in the other one okay so
here you see it's calling three so we
want to modify that if you used D SEC -
you're going to want to modify that
let's do save and
and one pipeline now in the meantime
let's take a look at the output so
output files post-processing and then
you have gauge and so under gauge you
will have many PNG files like this then
you can probably recognize the tech
pathways but also down here you have a
table
and so here again you have these
different pathway names and you can now
find them so let's take this first one
that's called ribosome right and you can
see it's number 0 3 0 1 0 so what's nice
about this is that we can see which you
know I don't know what ribosome pathway
necessarily means right but if we take
this name so if we go back to the table
right now I can google this ok and this
is the full pathway so I can see all of
the genes that are involved in this
pathway and this is basically the
picture that we saw today so the idea
behind this is that if we have
differential expression of genes between
just two groups we can then use those
values to generate enrichment analysis
with pathways and with annotated genes
and we can look through those genes and
we can look at those paths pathways and
we can order them by significance so
ammount of genes if we quickly look at
again you have p value q value and set
size your set size is the number of
genes in that path